but you're actually uh you had just told
me you were working with mac main now
who's helping you out so how did that
happen and shout out to mac main who's a
super nice guy really just just just
digging in the dirt not digging in there
just just digging around on some [ __ ]
like
he he we we keeping a relationship on
some oh [ __ ] and i'm telling like what's
going on with me
and [ __ ] like
bro i'm gonna help step in on some [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so it's just
one of them situation where like the
relationship that's why i try to tell
people all day every day like
relationship is is it it gets you
farther than money relationships are the
biggest currency there's more important
time in relationships yeah so
just me just me being me he brought a
couple play in my way then i told him
like what situation going on you like
man i got you lebron type [ __ ] you're
gonna get him out of michigan rap on
something for you i don't know he said
you know i ain't heard the [ __ ] rap
yeah he said he uh he said he said uh he
was [ __ ] around with this [ __ ]
which on my mac main right uh-huh you're
making a rap i ain't no you didn't i
never heard them bro some of these
freestyles back in the day i never heard
the mixtape [ __ ] i never heard them
yeah yeah the squad up [ __ ] i remember
club sky in tampa i did an after party
with wayne and mac main was there and i
forget which but i played a mac main
freestyle
because i was like yo if macmain comes
i'm just gonna drop this [ __ ] just right
so he'll be like [ __ ] all right now i
heard he he said he got something he
said he got some on that court too so
we're going to see about that [ __ ] yeah
get him out of retirement yeah you say i
will yeah you know lo used to rap too oh
lo you what
why don't you sign him he's been riding
with you this whole time
he's my manager man
his head needs to manage he don't need
to goddamn around no not [ __ ] put him
over hard lowe's hard for sure those are
real lyricists well i can't say well low
is a real lyric still still
we're about to find out when we throw
this beat on
you you got some fallout